I don't think success
and self-love are the same the mutually
or or they are mutually exclusive or you
know what I mean like
you
there are I mean it's unfortunate I wish
karmically that the world worked faster
that our existence worked faster I wish
that people doing shitty things felt the
brunt of that [__] faster it would
course correct a lot of people a lot a
lot more quickly I suppose you know and
maybe make it but that's just not how it
works and so yeah you can be very
successful and be a douchebag you can be
very successful and treat people very
poor and very successful and not love
yourself yeah sure yes yeah of course
but
uh
but I but I don't think again successes
success is a great marker sometimes I
think I've become more every time I go
and actually truly
show up for myself
uh um love myself look at areas of my
life that I need to like yo I need to be
smarter about this I need to be stronger
about this I need to be better about
this and I need to do it and I need to
keep that promise to myself every time I
do that in my life that's when really
wonderful things happen so I do think
that success can be a marker of you
loving yourself of doing the work that
real work the internal work that you
need to do right I agree with that I
think that I really believe that being
I'll just say that being a good person
and being generous and being humble and
um altruistic and all these things it if
nothing makes you just feel better and
makes you love yourself I think it's
helpful more I think it's helpful but I
guess what I would I would even go a
step further and say Focus less about
being generous and focus more about
again loving yourself and accepting
yourself and the more you're able to do
that the more you're able to do it with
other people the more the more you're
willing to accept that like oh my God I
I I
[__] up all the time and there are so
many things that I would rail you know
like my self-talk was so bad and all
that jazz that as soon as I just started
saying like hey it's not your fault
it's you know like straight up out of
Jerry Maguire or um now of a Goodwill
Hunting uh you know Robin Williams
looking at at Will Hunting saying uh at
uh Matt Damon it's not your fault it's
not your fault
that's true
but that means it's true of everyone
every single person every person and
you're saying so and so hear me out so
the internal work is recognizing that
you want to be generous yes generosity
as an act is a beautiful thing a
beautiful thing and everyone should do
it we're almost regardless of your
motive go be generous and by the way
generosity uh uh um then uh you know um
brings out gratitude and you know
gratitude scientific that's so cool
watch not even if you are practicing
gratitude brain changes dude if you
watch someone else show gratitude it's
almost more powerful than you your own
gratitude practice isn't that crazy yeah
if you watch out you know somebody help
an old lady did you see it well sure but
and and it encourages it in you you are
seeing example in the wild and go that
is good that is good to do and you want
somebody walking old lady across the
street and you see the old lady oh thank
you so much that's hugely powerful for
your own edification
real quick okay and then remember what
you're gonna say because otherwise I'm
gonna forget this yeah
but unfortunately
and you could help me out here
I feel that in order to love myself
I just if I'm more giving and I'm more
generous and I'm good to people and
maybe I'll I'll feel that maybe I'll
love myself more and unfortunately that
doesn't work and that's what I'm saying
it's not that's an outside in approach I
know but I I I I I try to find that
because I my analogy would be this is a
bad analogy but like let's say you're
I'm not but let's say you're you're uh
let's say in your life you've killed
some people okay and nobody knows about
it right I haven't killed anybody but
this is a bad analogy no no you've
killed people then you're like you know
what I'm not gonna kill anybody anymore
but I can't love myself because I've
killed before
okay
does that make sense to you it does I
don't that's a s that is a end of a
spectrum that I have a very hard time I
think I'm a don't use kill use uh let's
just say
um let's say no no it's fine I
understand what you're saying you say
what I'm saying you understand yeah okay
I get it so how does someone love
themselves when they know some of the
things they've done aren't lovable well
let me go next book let me let me let me
finish to the next book let me finish
this thought first Okay the reason I'm
even bringing that up about is because
I think it is it is far more uh
um when you work from the inside out the
the the generosity flows out you're not
trying to be generous to be a good
person you become a good and good and
bad person I I I mean healed more healed
more awake more aware more more capable
all of that you know but when you become
more of that by loving yourself by
radically accepting forgiving and loving
yourself
then what happens is automatically you
recognize as a logical person hopefully
you're a person you know that exercises
logic that in order to apply that to you
you have to apply to everyone else
because this logic is the same we are
all products of our environment that is
the [__] logic that's what it is